i can prove that when i put the mask
over the camera you can't see through it
blocks out all the lights
so there's no there's no
unfair play tricks yeah
okay
you're all white yes i'm playing jesse
february yeah your um
your last name is like earlier this year
your last name is early this year is one
of the comments
okay good luck great thank you she just
needs something
for him
uh before we start we're gonna play a
blitz game three plus two
i'll be blindfolded nemo who also has a
youtube and twitch channel
uh links will be below she'll make my
moves
and uh let's do this so there won't be
any odds i'm kind of heavily i mean i'm
not excited
so
you're fine you're fine
okay well let's not put that on youtube
okay so the youtube ad revenue will
cover the the okay
oh don't worry about it this is how it
goes i chesterman's the oldest one
always
all right eric just paid her a bill so
guys please click like and subscribe
[Music]
okay so are you ready i was born ready
three
two one go okay d4
oh no it's dead it's london time
bishop f4
eric why why not
g6
knight c3
d5
e3
it's joe bava london bishop g7 yes i saw
that h4
go jesse h5
anyone here to cheer me on
let's go eric
we'll take a photo please uh knight f3
knight to f3 okay
b6
you're prepared
play 95.
all right
bishop e7
b7 yeah bishop b7 okay uh queen of three
queen of three
stop being aggressive
i can't help myself
she play knight to dc knight b d7
i'll play bishop b5
fossil i can't see your tear but i can
hear your fear we should probably keep
it down
i'll play queen to g3
knight takes e5
bishop takes e5
knight to e4
do you take c4
jc is so concentrated
play bishop c4
bishop c4
it doesn't work
it doesn't work i know i know
i'll play
when you don't get your attack it's hard
when i can't admire my nice position
how's the london bishop eric it's gone
green d6 yeah
oh that's so tricky that's about some
wonderful fishes i know
you want to do that
i don't want to do it
i'll play queen
to
b5 queen to b5
you have 90 seconds thank you how much
time does she have 2 minute 14.
oh no my time
okay take your time thank you you're
welcome
a6
queen d3
b5 ambitious e2
bishop d5 queen c3
stop hurting me
not intentionally
i don't know if you're hurting me or
just massaging my pieces
that doesn't sound very crazy
this is a good christian youtube channel
yeah
okay
85
85.
okay let's have some fun let's play g4
you have one minute 12 seconds
you don't have to return the favor you
know
it's not the massage for massage
this is more like acupuncture
what's the chinese cupping thingamajig
that they do like the one where they put
like a ball it makes chinese yeah that's
chinese lots of things h takes g4 bishop
i just call it the karate kid
e5
oh you have two e pawns what is this
oh it's getting spicy it's called double
trouble let's play
queen side castling
all right
oh no my apon
oh no
not fun don't listen to him jesse
he's trying to disturb you
but now i want to take it
it should be fine to take it
what if it's like reverse psychology
everything in life is free that could be
possible actually
i was thinking about that right surely
it's okay
wait did she take my part yeah she does
bishop takes a2 you heard that the sound
effects were there i think we read you
yeah correctly reverse psychology okay
let's play h5
h5 oh no my king
that's okay i just block him just block
him
you know this pawn it's actually
defending your king yeah
the aston g5
g5
that's the spirit you have 40 seconds
thank you you should run master playing
field go follow me okay i'll play queen
well i was about to blunder my queen
before
uh
i'll play each six
30 seconds okay
get ready to move fast
f5 uh h7
b3
queen seafood
27 seconds she has 20.
you're controlling it time scramble time
queen to b4
wow
uh
wow
ten seconds
uh queen takes before
no wait uh oh
don't hurt me
did i get him he takes b4
[Music]
you have four seconds rookie two
b take c3 c2 rook take c2
bishop e3
uh rook to c5 okay that'll be time
i think you're going to see six and sub
queen to be four so i forgot there's a
pawn on c7 congratulations
so when i took on b4 i thought rook
takes c2 as mates
not realizing there's still a pawn here
yeah at least there was an escape in
this position
because i thought yeah it takes me
um yeah
okay if this goes on youtube say
congrats to jesse
um stay tuned for more content